Hey, Tony, it's me. Yeah, it's me, Juan. I have a favorite serious favorite can ask for you. Can I borrow your car for a couple hours? I need to head downtown.
Oh, well, for I need a.
This is kind of embarrassing, but I need to pick up my cat from the bed.
Yeah, she's kind of just please.
Yeah, I need to pick her up because if I don't pick her up now, they're gonna charge me an extra $100 overnight.
And right now, even though, like, you know, I love the cat, you know, but $100 is not worth it. And then
Look, I know that little Jimmy scratch you up and everything, but he's a cat. He's a wild animal. Please. This is not affecting him. It's affecting me.
The hundred dollars can go a long way. I could be opening packs right now.
Let me open them.
Look, look, look, look, look.
There, please. I get on my knees. I'm getting on my knees. I need to speak. I need to speak.
I'm gonna need to borrow your car for a couple hours to I failed to get a couple hours to max. I figured fill out your tank.
I even vacuum your car, please. I do anything right now. Please.